baker mayfield was not happy that the
game ended that way and the browns had a
chance to knock the ravens out they were
watching the game in pittsburgh like it
was a drive-in movie it was great what a
scene that was as it all played out in
real time but baker mayfield had no
interest in stopping and shaking hands
and it wasn't look and this is part of
what he'll learn from maturity you have
to slow down in those moments accept the
fact that you lost the game you go shake
the hand
quarterback yeah i don't think lamar
jackson was happy about that but lamar
jackson was very happy that the ravens
won the game and they advanced to the
postseason this
sunday against the charter they met up
after the game again and gave another
hug and had a talk too so okay well
don't don't don't reign on my narrative
with that exactly right how dare i do
that and set that straight but i think
one thing it does do just again is shows
the respect that other teams and other
players have for baker mayfield once
again just even though he threw three
interceptions yesterday he had moments
just like lamar jackson did and we'll
talk about the ravens the second where
we just went wow i mean baker mayfield
every week he has delivered uh he's done
more than that and cleveland should just
be pumped up because he is uh got
superstar written all over him yeah and
i think he's the offensive rookie of the
year i think you and i have argued about
that at the time you think it should be
saquon barkley but look at the impact
that baker mayfield has had on the
browns look at where the browns were at
owen 16 last year 1-15 the year before
that he has changed everything and i
think it's even more significant when
you consider the 20 years of futility
that they've had at the quarterback
position the revolving door that jersey
with all the names stretching down to
the floor and now it's going to be
mayfield barring injury it's going to be
mayfield for the next 15 to 18 years and
they're in position to go out and hire a
great coach they're in position to make
things happen they've got games next
year we're going to want to see in prime
time
look i want i want the browns to be in
the playoffs just because i want to
continue to watch him play yeah i know i
understand that that's the way he is
that's the kind of guy a game he has
that's why we've talked about him being
a smaller brett favre over all those
type of things because he is he's a
gunslinger he's got tremendous
self-confidence and you could tell that
he's got leadership skills all right
let's get let's go
the ravens are in the postseason
and uh
look the ravens and chargers if you're
the patriots if you're the chiefs if
you're any other team in the afc field
you are very happy that these two are
playing each other because these are the
two you don't want to see you're right
the worst case scenario would have been
ravens colts texans chargers then you
got to worry about ravens and chargers
advancing to the division around but the
and look look look
if the texans hold serve at home against
the colts which is no guarantee the
patriots get the easy draw relative to
what the chiefs are going to face the
chiefs are going to face the winner of
ravens chargers in kansas city we'll be
there for that one division around
coming up in a couple of saturdays but
with the ravens winning
with the colts beating the titans last
night we have the playoff picture set in
the afc but i hadn't seen it and really
paid attention to it yeah that stark of
a term right raven's chargers it's very
good for the patriots that they're not
in that bracket unless there's an upset
if the colts beat the texans then which
we know that can happen so you know
that's what i mean the colts hey the one
thing that we've learned watching sunday
night football last night they have
things that are elite about their
football team the first thing is is
their offensive line right i mean we
talk about that on a weekly basis how
they can dominate a game and they did
that again last night uh they ended up
winning by a wide margin but really
we're dominating throughout kind of let
the tennessee titans crawl back into the
game but that uh then coupled with
andrew luck and a defense that's kind of
opportunistic and it doesn't hurt to
have blaine gabbard out there but i
still look at the colts as dangerous
certainly and then you talk about the
ravens i mean what we're seeing from the
ravens right now too just getting back
to that this is like this is
groundbreaking stuff we're watching like
the the 1970 nebraska oklahoma team uh
in the nfl it's like the nfl version of
the wishbone what they're doing right
now and i think it's it is refreshing to
see it was crazy to see uh cleveland
kind of struggle with some of those
concepts in the run game yesterday but
the afc i think is it's amazing how wide
open it is once again and i really look
at one all six teams legitimately and go
we can make a case for any of them to go
to the super bowl and make it there
according to match-ups kind of like what
you're saying peter king points out in
football morning in america that in the
seven games quarterbacked by lamar
jackson the ravens have rushed for 267
yards 242 207 194 242 159 and
296 on sunday jackson had 90 on 20
carries and two touchdowns would have
had a third coaching point for lamar
jackson and any other quarterback if
you're going to go up and over drew
brees style don't pull the ball back
keep going forward because the moment
you kiss the front of the goal line the
play's over it doesn't matter if the
ball comes out right you don't have to
get cue with it and try to yo-yo it back
yeah because he stopped short yo-yo
tonight oh i stopped short he stopped
short and he pulled it back and then it
should have been a touchdown the other
way for the browns which could have
changed everything you look good in your
vikings uh i feel good you sweat are
doing that little ball dive there too
well that's something we won't be seeing
and anyone wearing purple this year
unless it's lamar jackson lamar jackson
a different kind of purple all together
but you're right they they that was
here's the thing here's the thing right
yeah is it sustainable right is what
they're doing sustainable if lamar lamar
jackson gets hurt you're gonna have to
load up your depth chart with guys who
can run that offense you can't have a
joe flacco you got to have rg3 you got
to have another guy behind him and you
you just have to commit to it all in
because injuries are the thing that can
derail this approach i agree with that i
think that's yes for the best thing for
your team as far as going forward and
having you know fail-safe plans uh for
the future yeah you need quarterbacks
with a similar skill set to lamar
jackson i do think he can handle it you
know yes he takes a few big hits every
game but it's not i don't get concerned
with it overall as a whole i still go
that's a good job just kind of getting
out of the uh the squareness of that
shot or sliding to where they just got
an edge of them but yes uh it's it's
living dangerously but either way the
ravens have found a formula that fits
them and i think the guy that first of
all we have to give credit to is greg
roman there that's the one guy when i
watch film with them on a weekly basis
that always pops into my head greg roman
the architect of the colin kaepernick
offense out in san francisco his ability
to add these type of plays uh in the
backfield with the misdirection and
pulling guards and all these read option
type of wrinkles they have that is
because of him and his ability to work
with marty morningwag and that's where i
think it's awesome about the ravens too
and you know i think that the earliest
indications that the ravens were
thinking about moving in this direction
came in july of 2017 when they were
linked to colin kaepernick remember that
yes and they backed off quickly
but they were linked to him and then
within a year after that they draft
lamar jackson in the first round they
bring in rg3 they brought rg3 and i
think just before that but they are
embracing this alternative offense and
as long as you're the only team in the
league doing it maybe it works sure if
it proliferates then you have a problem
it's almost like there was a time when
not many teams were doing the 3-4
defense so
not every team could deal with it
because you don't see it very often and
tony dungy made a great point last night
the chargers right
are seeing this again it was just nine
days ago right that they faced it and
now they're gonna face it again in six
days
and will you be better at stopping it
the second time around yeah that will be
an advantage for the chargers in that
aspect to just go okay this is what they
did to us the players will be better
prepared as far as you know little keys
and stopping the run game and all the
you know the window dressing they do
behind the line of scrimmage i'll say
this though the ravens will also go oh
this is what they did and we can adjust
our run game off of that it's going to
be one of the fascinating matchups of
the weekend you know those are two of
the top teams in the afc playing in the
wild card round that's where it's going
to be a lot of fun and again the
patriots
assuming
that the texans beat the colts the
patriots get lucky because the colts win
they go to kansas city if the texans win
the chiefs get the winner of that ravens
chargers game and they're going to be in
trouble it's a horrible matchup in my
opinion for the houston texans like this
would be one of those where i'd go for
houston i'd go man this is the one team
i don't think they wanted to see because
their d-line gets muted a little bit in
this matchup right the greatness of the
texans is that front four they can make
a mess of the game and i can tell you
one offensive line that's not going to
let that front four make a mess of the
game is the indianapolis colts and
that's the great evening fat or you know
what do i want to say equalizing yeah
thank you you are the mess that's good
morning to you and happy new year sire
how are you
what's up hi how are you all right now
we're done with you stats back to the
games and you know i i but i hadn't
really thought of this matchup there
just because the colts winning that game
would allow the chiefs to avoid the
winner of ravens chargers that's no
picnic for the cults and chiefs if
that's the team that kansas city is
welcoming to arrowhead stadium i mean
what was it 38 to 10 in the third
quarter a few years ago and the colts
came back and bought the chiefs chiefs
right a playoff game at home since joe
montana was the quarterback that
narrative is going to take root over the
next 12 days before they play on that
saturday and just look
congratulations chiefs you're the top
seed congratulations chiefs but mike
florio is going to doubt you every
second until you actually win a home
playoff game and we're never going to
hear the end of it is there anything
wrong with that no there's not it's got
it and the fact that we're going to be
at arrowhead stadium for that game maybe
i should start sucking up yeah you
should and it's our buddies there you
know it's a different year because our
homie patrick mahomey mvp i agree with
you now okay
yeah i get you i think he did i think he
cemented that yesterday but uh yeah it's
a weird year in the afc because there is
no true dominant team every team has
flaws every team has some great
strengths on their on their team in some
area and it's as wide open as i can ever
remember i i if you had to pick a team
in the afc right now who would you go
patriots you'd go patriots just because
of the playoff experience yeah i know
that's everything else is and there was
a time yesterday during the patriots
jets game where tom brady was looking
like tom brady yeah rob gronkowski was
looking like rob gronkowski it's like
you know they set us up right not that
they did it deliberately but they had
that period of time we're always probing
for when the patriots are finally gonna
fall apart and we thought it was
happening and the patriots are still the
patriots and i think that's the team
assuming look that if the ch even if the
chiefs hold serve in the division around
and the patriots have to go there i i
think there's not going to be fear
they're not and and they have experience
and they're not going to freak out and
they're going to deliver and i think
it's going to be right now i'd have to
say patriot saints would be the two
teams that you'd go with okay super bowl
one team that won't make it to the super
bowl because they're not making the
playoffs minnesota 84 million investment
in kirk cousins the vikings they blow it
we'll break that down and also what got
to eat will you stop it and some of your
sweaters
did to get in we'll check back with more
pft right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports